well before my friend
you used to be the king in the rain you
wrestled for glory
punished your opponents he stayed in
shape
what happened we just window me shows me
more you kind of lose a block Fergus and
I did I miss the physicality of a match
I must cheating and getting away with it
and I definitely miss my friends if
someone asks you why you're interesting
and saying that it's all fake what do
say well I'd say get in the ring and
have a go and see what it's like and see
the hard work dedication death Lewis
isn't something we'll have someone goes
down and it looks like a nasty fall and
have no idea whether they're actually
legitimately hurt even though you said
nearly known you're watching a bit of a
soap opera you've got this mystery about
it and it never know what part is real
and yeah
Wilberforce
you will teach me your art and ever I
remember your best self what if my
wrestling character embodied your
weaknesses like blazes I could wear your
mask I don't want to take public
knowledge that have got sleep apnea so
that's something I'll wave the flag off
hey I'm a failure working it's awesome
let's hope mr. thunder go back can we
make a film is about seriously unlike
their I sure Nick Linda Oubre fires or
Fatiha where you're so fatty fatty one
point you just want to show everyone
this is my friend he does nothing that's
what you're trying to vote you and me
and me setting out to make this film and
get you off your arse it's on the little
tools you can create drama
you just used implements you're not
being a friend over
Hoss
you